well let's speak out to pedasi didi in
New Delhi he's a social media
entrepreneur and campaigner and lives
near the University where some of these
nights protests took place good to have
you with us on the news hour given your
proximity to those protests can you just
quickly give us a sense of what has
actually been happening there alright so
we had that brutal crackdown yesterday
India time and we of course understand
that you know a lot of these people are
faced had to suffer injuries we're
getting numbered beyond 100 some people
say that some of those injuries are also
very serious some of the students also
ended up being in I see yous
this morning we saw some of the the
protests also protesters coming back to
the streets but this time the the
protests were not any and there was no
violence or any activity per se most of
the protests today that we saw in the
Daniell Nagar area were largely symbolic
some young people came up and they took
off their shirts as a sign of saying
that you know we will resist you and
this and and it continues to be
nonviolent so yes so we've seen
commotion all day today there is a very
heavy presence of the police and and the
security deployment in the entire
neighborhood you know there's this
constant communication between the
police and the locals where the police
is also trying to give them a sense of
what what is a good time to be out on
the streets and perhaps after after the
sundown for 6 o'clock onwards the same
says that that you do disperse we've
seen unprecedented deployment of the
police in the entire neighborhood so
that's largely something that people are
now really looking looking at by the
same time if you really talk to the
locals it seems that you know they're
they're moved in in terms of wanting to
make a statement or wanting to be part
of the resistance that hasn't gone
anywhere even after that that crackdown
that we saw yesterday okay - tell us
more about these students what would you
say is the significance of the
participation of students in these
process I mean are these Oh Muslim
students is this a Muslim only issue or
are there wiser ways of issues at play
here I see first of all it's important
to understand that the way the law
design it in the design itself there
there seems to be an attack on the
Muslim community and that's how the
community is really perceiving it so
there is no denying the fact that that
it is the Muslim community that that is
more nervous then perhaps the rest of
the country but having said that a let's
not take away the fact that the protest
may have started at say the jamia
University which is a predominantly
University where Muslims would usually
go and also protests at another
university called the illegal Muslim
University both of these almost starting
at around the same time both of them
predominantly you know led by by
students from the Muslim community but
then what we've seen is especially after
the crackdown that happened at Jamia
Millia Islamia first and then followed
by a legal Muslim University yesterday
are we seen that this is not spiraling
to other universities all over India
we're seeing at you know at colleges in
Mumbai in college even in Lucknow in
Hyderabad we've seen some of those
protests being very symbolic in nature
well some others perhaps being very you
know showing signs of violence as well
they've been given instances of
stone-throwing as well so so yes so it's
important to understand that if you know
you might really see organized young
people coming together and yet they it's
not like one one large model monolith of
a protest there is a scale and there is
a big spectrum of the kind of protests
that we are seeing some of them
extremely peaceful just symbolic when
others perhaps getting out of hand
showing the signs of nervousness that
I'm getting them okay but also you do
have to leave it there but thank you
very much indeed bring us all the latest
there from New Delhi